bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fatti j
e oggi siamo di nuovo su penombra
mi voglio allora voglio partire soltanto
dicendomi la cosa mi voglio scusare
perché praticamente l'ultima cosa che
avete visto nell'ultimo episodio era io
che correvo dai ragni e poi sono
riuscito ad entrare in questa porta qui
voglio soltanto dirvi che è praticamente
ho fatto due passi in più cioè nel senso
sono sono entrato va dentro sono andato
in una stanza che più avanti che adesso
ci andiamo e ho trovato degli oggetti
che sono tipo questa è forse la sega non
sono dicono se ce l'aveva comunque
trovato un paio di oggetti ecco quella
parte non è registrata per il semplice
fatto che mi si è pagato il file di
registrazione di prima perché l'ho
registrata appunto prima comunque vi
dico non è successo niente sono
semplicemente entrato qua dentro
e entrato nella stanza che c'è qua
sinistra che adesso vi faccio vedere
comunque mi scuso per questo equivoco
che c'è stato però ogni tanto il mio
computer decide di riavviarsi quando non
deve e perde i file di registrazione
comunque sono entrati in questa stanza
qui che vedete e ho preso degli oggetti
che si trovavano su sti scaffali tutto
qua non sono andato più avanti di così è
praticamente in sostanza qua ci ho
trovato tipo o il cacciavite non mi
ricorda qualcosa
e basta non sono più andato avanti ok
raga continuo perché non mi ricordo dove
ero rimasto l'ultima volta c'è nel senso
non mi ricordo cosa dovevo fare
una volta scavatori ragni sono entrato
qui ma non so proprio cosa devo fare
entrato cessa porta che non ho provato
ad aprire un'altra porta di sicurezza
suppongo mi serva il codice ma perché
fanno così perché perché così tante
misure cautelative minchia che parolone
raga per me è già tanto e non lo so va
beh comunque noi non possiamo aprirla
spacchiamo le scatole o rompiamo le
scatole
c'è un coso anno devo mettere il codice
che non so ovviamente metto a caso
mettiamo 5.000 supponendo che sia un
codice a quattro cifre sono circa 10.000
possibile combinazioni se proprio si va
beh ho capito non il tiro a caso stai
tranquillo e prendiamo le altre strade
raga perché ce n'erano altre quindi vado
andiamo a sinistra
certo scatolone norma inutile che bello
stare sono belli si posi ti invogliano
ad andare avanti o cazzo non l'avevo
visto c'è un cane benissimo raga e c'è
anche un coso voi sapete come sono bravo
nel uccidere i cani costi cosi vero
faccio ogni volta un file ma ci devo
provare
ci devo provare innanzitutto per solcare
certi in parte
ok ok no no no no no no no no no no ti
prego ti prego stai calma se siamo stai
calmo non mi visivo no no ok perfetto si
è acceso si è acceso esplode
no no no no no no no no no dove scappato
bene bene bene bene bene bene c'è una
porta entriamo il trianon sta arrivando
lo sta arrivando un suono perfetto
perfetto forse lo seminato certamente sì
è [ __ ] acceso no no no no no no apri
due no 292 no calmi calmissimi perfetto
bene me la sono vista bruttissima la
porta è chiusa
devo tornare indietro e ci sono due cani
che che mi stanno aspettando quindi non
è proprio il massimo e se possibile
rischio se riesco a girare st fare in
qualche modo magari mi proteggo
salendoci sopra però non riesco a
girarlo
ok succede quando finestra oddio sui
denti anche due cose e voi ancora perché
stai facendo così kozuch ai l'emorragia
ok sono di nuovo sono scappati
io ragazze riesco mi porto il barile in
giro se riesco bene ok ok stanno
tornando via
ok perfetto devo riuscire ad aprire il
cancello si si apre bene bene bene bene
bene bene ok ti chiudi si dove di questo
dove di questo non lo puoi prendere
questo non lo zio lato no no no no no no
non chiudi chiudi chiudi donna questa di
massa da intrecci bravo
ok bene ho fatto un file assurdo devo
riuscire a chiudere a tappare la porta
con il barile perfetto
ok mi ci metto anche sopra perfetto o no
no no tu non puoi passare tu non puoi
passare
ok raga riesco anche a prenderli
attraverso dal cancello perfetto cos'è
sta roba intanto facciamo così io vado
dall'altra parte sperando di trovare
un'altra strada e mi porto al barile che
mi ha salvato la vita più volte beh no
no no no no no no non ti rovesciare sono
rovinato perfetto
[Musica]
non mi ha visto non mi ha visto perfetto
non so cosa devo fare la gara
non so cosa devo fare non ne ho idea c'è
una mappa qui non ci sono cani perfetto
allora sono andato nel tool su rage
perfetto non ho paura a guardarmi
indietro c'è un cane in fondo che non
che stanno andare ad altra parte però
allora siamo qui raffineria che provo ad
andare in fondo a sinistra ci provo
sperando di incontrare altri cani dovrei
trovare ok no corri corri corri corico a
ricordi prefetto non mi ha visto mi ha
visto mi ha visto corri corri con
madonna ma la domanda sembra oddio mi
sono ragazzi sono catapultato dentro la
porta letteralmente va bene così e va
bene così
dove sono non mi interessa basta che non
ci sono cani
non ne posso più questo calo colleghi e
pulsanti alla pressa quali pulsanti a
questi qua sotto perfetto
bene bene bene mi sono ok
devo devo fare qualcosa così pulsanti ma
non idea di che cosa debba fare
e successo che cosa
cos'è ah sì ok ok ok bene bene bene
praticamente sta macchina serve per fare
dei mega biscotti quando passa la
l'impasto devo cliccare il tasto momento
giusto
niente faccio i biscotti poche parole
l'utilità è alle stelle mi sono anche
fatto male
basta ce l'ho fatta ho capito cioè io ho
iniziato sempre che ci riesco a passare
se ci riesco
ok speriamo di non diventare una
sottiletta dal momento all'altro
perfetto
ok ci ho messo un'ora la gara mente
delle della mia mente sono paragonati a
ciò che stai vedendo ma stai zitto
cogliere tu mi hai fatto passare in
mezzo ai rami non me lo dimenticherò mai
è una bomba nucleare
completerà questa era che una bomba
nucleare fragilissima da maneggiare con
molta attenzione o mio dio
oh mio dio bene benissimo a me non è
successo niente
vabbè prendiamo tutta sta roba intanto
che cosa persona roccia la rock ciak
inutile
questo
questo nastro trasportatore di impiccio
mettiamoci una bomba ragazze di mente
che cosa ci trovate questa roba
la cosa stupida non è che devo mettere
il tipo questo
nel nastro questo qua credo è poi boh
non lo so
e andata non so dove mai andata è andata
non so dove ma è andata quindi se si
potrà mentre vuol dire che ha qualcosa
serviva va bene comunque a parte tutto
questo proviamo ad andare via dal suo
posto perché già vista sul culo
ecco ci sono rocce inutili vari lì ok in
tronco ha dentro
non so che perfetto bene è stata è stata
bella la nostra scampagnata abbiamo già
finito non era sinceramente non so che
devo fare con sesto posto c'è qualcosa
indietro no e allora che cosa mi hai
fatto venire perché
e allora perché sono entrato qui dentro
spiegatemelo va bene noi proseguite
proseguiamo non so cosa devo fare
forse raga devo tirare giù in qualche
modo la scala non ho idea
ok ok ok ok perfetto mi ha preso in
testa la radio che è successo beh allora
è caduta la scala e ho trovato una bomba
a caso senza motivo
va bene non facciamoci domanda e saliamo
cazzo è successo ragazzi non ho capito
che cosa è successo però è caduta la
bomba
cioè non è non so co vabbè passo possa
farsi domanderà che inutile tanto
questa roba qua sopra e tentò di salire
che faccio saltare in aria la ventola se
riesco
intanto questa roba qui non ho capito
che serve trova bene cos'è quel nastro
deve uscire da questo buco e spiega mi
l'utilità del nastro cioè non ha senso
provate ok ok non ha fatto bene bene non
sta facendo
fuck yeah non so come ho fatto però la
bomba ci è riuscito a tener fermo il la
palla perfetto la rotta bene ok
grandissima è una bomba che fa di tutto
tranne esplodere ma va bene così
va bene così perché finché non riusciamo
a proseguire e va tutto bene
capelli stanno mangiando la faccia
praticamente ok la radio sta
trasmettendo basta parte stai zitto stai
zitto zitto noto il mio amore mamma di
questa razza di depravato
usciamo di qua fatemi uscire in porta
l'olio nissa macchinario sembra integra
una manca solo un motore si tanto
una roba così a caso manca solo il pezzo
principale praticamente ovviamente
funzione sta cosa
spiegatemi il motore a bomba la roba
rossa sarebbe la il motore cioè io l'ho
scambiato per una bomba a tutto il tempo
che i ragazzi taglio finché non lo
prendo ok sto tornando col motore sto
tornando col motore che veramente finora
ho scambiato per sembrava una bomba c'è
tutta rossa c'erano quelle bombe
subacquee che hanno anche le spine però
vabbè è un motore evidentemente quindi
utilizziamolo come motore
e vabbè basta accendiamo vai così o le
riparazioni funzionali in 4 secondi
funziona come un orologio ma che per la
sorpresa speriamo che non ci sia anche
il botto
bene adesso ragazzaccio direttamente io
ok draga vado sullo scivolo adesso mi
faccio questo tipo al lavaggio auto
adesso mi mi passano gli stracci e mi
puniscono per bene dove sono finito
e questo sarebbe il lavaggio o una roba
del genere cazzo devo fare qui
ok rago capitone funziona praticamente
devo passare in sezione qui dove ecco
tipo questa dove ogni tanto non passa al
calore soltanto che non mi ricordo bene
la sequenza
praticamente ci finisco secco perché non
so arrivare alla fine
ci provo lo stesso bye bye bilancio
bilancio sì non ci posso credere non ci
posso credere ho saltato tutto
ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta ce l'ha
fatta
vado avanti prosegue perché voglio
uscire di qua prima possibile questa
porta e sigillata non me ne frega niente
non me ne frega niente adesso tu da aprì
subito sono mezzo morto non me ne frega
aprila subito non si apre perfetto
raga non si apre la foto non ha senso
forse devo girare la valvola lì no
ok ho capito forse devo c'è un passaggio
qua perfetto perfetto credevo di essere
bloccato mi son cagato addosso credetemi
però vabbè vai così a vuoto proprio non
ho neanche lei la torcia non vedo niente
perfetto
meno male che c'è sempre mio amichetto
bengala che mi aiuta perché se non vede
veramente nulla raga
allora via il piccone non so dove sto
andando non chiedetemi c'è un terremoto
possono semplicemente io che ciò gli
spasmi perfetto sono io vado vado avanti
perché non so veramente dove sto andando
non ne ho idea
c'è una grata quelli che mi sento molto
solid snake in questo caso perché sono
uscito
sono uscito senza motivo però sono
uscito dal condotto per dove sono cos'è
sto posto
ok io toglierei carrello e sbloccare la
porta prevedere
chiamo probabilmente dove c'erano i cani
prima raga una roba del genere perché
non sono non avrebbe senso che la porta
era bloccata dal carrello tra l'altro a
questa era la porta bloccata ok che mi
stava facendo uccidere praticamente per
colpa di suo carrello ci stavo finendo
secco [ __ ]
ecco questo ci stava ebbene c'è chiuso
completamente non c'ero mai più di qua
vabbè binari il carrello per il
trasporto di minerali per quattro sono
comunemente usati ancora oggi mi sembra
che non vengano usati proprio in questa
miniera
ho questo presentimento però vabbè non
possiamo farci un giretto turistico sì
direi di sì se riesco a sfondare no non
si può fare queste cante ne mantengono
il carrello imposizione perfetto via con
la sega non si tagliano perfetto ora
vado avanti a piedi pazienza intanto io
sto morendo però facciamo finta di
niente
c'è una porta muro tra questo muro è
nuovo il cemento e così fresco non ha
più di una settimana
cosa sta succedendo guarda se fossi in
te io ci lancerà il carrello a tutta
velocità il problema è che ci sono le
catene che lo tengono fermo e come
faccio ad utilizzarlo non lo so ma va
bene così
proviamoci lo stesso non si tolgono le
catene deve riuscire a toglierle in
qualche modo quale chiuso cessa questa
sta qui che non ha senso
e vabbè qua probabilmente ci devo
tornare in un secondo momento raga devo
andare da qualche altra parte
gli studi non ci torno grazie ma no
faccio il giro perché lo russo dove devo
andare sinceramente vado da prova ad
entrare in qualche altra porta adesso
vedo cosa riesco a fare che cazzo
successo
ok otterremo
ma cos'è ragazza è un terremoto a caso a
random prima non c'erano i terremoti
sono mica i cani che saltano no non sono
loro vero stai di buono guardo un barile
non hai mai visto un bari resi l'hai
visto l'hai visto l'hai visto dai visto
bene bene non mi ha visto che non ti
girare non tanti girare fabi non ti ha
visto non ti preoccupare non ti agosto
perfetto basta basta concentrarsi e
credere che sia tutto tranquillo bene
benissimo qua qua non c'era ancora
passato tra l'altro o dei brutti ricordi
con l'ultimo cancello ma quando questa è
una leva tra l'altro a caso pesante
successo addio
oddio no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
[Musica]
e morto e molto dai vapori sono troppo
forte ci sono sono riuscito a uccidere
il cane col vapore senza senza farci
caso ragano è fantastico
ci sono riuscito totti sta bene toh
guarda non sono soddisfattissimo va bene
così tra l'altro ci lascia neanche una
fetta di carne così da farlo affumicata
però va bene così
allora l'utilità di quei vapori era
semplicemente uccidere i cani è
ovviamente era anche una buona idea se
vogliono ci avevo pensato prima tutto
qua siamo qui chef 13 cos'è chef 13 non
lo so ma andiamoci perché ancora non ci
sono entrato de qua sinistra destro
perfetto ho il presentimento che sarà
chiuso non so perché no invece aperto
strana nostrano va bene così
finalmente un qualcosa di aperto
normalmente lo troviamo perché sennò non
andiamo più avanti veramente cosa al suo
posto
che bello devo mica figli mi infilarmi
di dentro novero a che bello una roccia
mi blocca il passaggio non posso passare
perfetto allora vado dall'altra parte
l'ultima volta che sono entrato in
condotti del genere esatto
sì esatto era quello che temevo l'ultima
volta che sono entrato qui dentro non ho
avuto un buon ricordo
no ti prego no ok raga scusatemi per il
taglio e scusate se ho cambiato anche
vestiti nel frattempo ma ho deciso di
perché partita sta musica
vabbè comunque ho deciso di penombra
cazzo no no no no no no no no no no no
no va bene basta
ok ok
no ci siamo capiti male stavo dicendo
penombra ho deciso di fare episodi
lunghissimi così perché voglio finire
presto per fare spazio ad altre serie
così a chi è interessato almeno si
guarda l'episodio è enorme e chi non è
interessato bonum massimo non lo guarda
così almeno lo finisco prima cerco di
fare episodi più lunghi quindi per
questo mi vedete con la maglia diversa
non è che sono uno di quelli che si
cambia in 4 secondi però ho deciso di
tagliare appunto per unire due episodi
sono tornato qui a roma di massi in
questo condotto che non è un condotto
solo caverne ci sono i ragno che adesso
dove cercare di correre fino alla fine
ci provo ok vado
ok ok ok ok ok ok che via via a sinistra
non so dove andare vado vado a caso vado
a caso a casa ok mi sta beccando vista
peccando non di qua di qua l'offerto non
so dove andare
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
sì sì non ci credo non ci credo l'ho
saltato dai dai dai che lei non di qua
non di merda merda
devo riuscire a seminarlo al più presto
e ancora dietro si cazzo sì sì sono
uscito prenditi st sedia in faccia no mi
piaceva dei salti assurdi
bene bene bene no 222 deve uscire deve
uscire come si esce
come si esce come si esce come si
articola come sia esse di qua
no no no no no no che schifo
chi può ok mi ha avuto l'idea gli è
venuta di darmi molto l'idea mi è venuta
l'idea
[ __ ] ok sono ragni che resistono le
rocce enormi ok ok ok c'è una roccia
abbastanza grossa da bloccare il
passaggio forse la sedia basta no no
cazzo dov'è [ __ ] rai annunci dei
no no va bene devo affrontarla ragano un
pozzo
ok ok forse riesco dai dai
l'ho preso e ancora mio no
raga e vincibile soragna merda merda
doveste dov'è
[ __ ]
i ragazzi mi fa troppo schifo noi no mi
fa troppo schifo dove dove cazzo
no no dov'è [ __ ] ok l'ho preso
l'ho preso l'ho preso di nuovo di mori o
potremo così che schifo che mi fa mori
e morto non lo so se è morto non
vogliono trovare cos'è questo scrivo
questo affinché non lo so ora
galleggiate voi perché non tengo non
sono proprio dell'umore di leggere
ok dovreste riuscire a stoppare nelle
pagine per chi vuole leggere ma io non
leggo non c'è più
non c'è più non c'è più non c'è più
non c'è più
ti tiro una scarpa
va bene non so dove è andato ma non c'è
più non è rassicurante come cosa io me
ne devo andare di qua le scarpe che
casini se non è scatta tirare contro i
raggi
questa è una saponetta carne essiccata
che schifo
raga io devo devo finire al più presto
anche sto gioco perché odio i ragni
cos'è sta roba
nel mezzo ok mi sono messo nel mezzo
raga cosa ha senso
cos'è
altra carne e basta raga io devo uscire
di qua in fretta perché la radio sto
trasmettendo stronzo non è no no non ho
proprio voglia di parlare con te adesso
guarda non è il momento
se ne raga questo è un maniaco da questo
è un libro la bibbia trovato la bibbia
cazzo mi serve bene
non so che a ok devo togliere la roccia
perfetto dai talk ok facciamo così
venuta un'idea
facciamo così facciamo così facciamo
allora piano chiamano
ok ho provato a passare no no no cos'è
no non ci credo non ci credo
no no no no no e dai con ricordi dove
che schifo
[Musica]
raga non possono fare le cose però dico
sinceramente non posso che cazzo succede
ma il terremoto pure io non li sopporto
i rami non li sopporto mi fanno troppo
schifo troppo troppo schifo
cosa cosa ho trovato poi una dinamica e
cosa ho trovato niente
no non ci credo non è possibile
sono due ore che giro a caso e poi
dovevo fare sta troiata con no non ci
credo io pensavo che dovevo fare
qualcosa che sta roba qua postale va
vabbè lasciamo perdere allora ragazzo lo
spingo giu credo se riesco lo spingo
giunto per riuscire a sfondare il muro
ok magari in salvo anche sopra no meglio
non salirci sopra magari finisco secco
però dovrei riuscire a sfondare il muro
di in fondo dai bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye raga tre ore che giro a caso e
non sono riuscito a trovare niente
adesso dopo non so quanto
ce l'ho fatta anche posso anche salvare
sento sentite sento qualcuno che parla
io salvo comunque due ore due fottute
ore stai zitto non voglio leggere niente
sono incazzato va beh quando l'uso sento
di non essere solo se fossi uno tra i
tanti visitatori molto strano eh si vede
che è una roba connessa online comunque
qua c'è un microscopio il giorno senza
tino superato che cosa me ne frega delle
microscopio quando posso difendermi con
una matita
vabbè non ha senso ma noi proseguiamo
prima di aprire i cassetti se c'è
qualcosa non c'è niente cos'è vecchio
quotidiano devo leggerlo molto rovinato
praticamente illeggibile e allora non mi
interessa
che schifo è ma che schifo oddio nova
perché mi capitò anche cagato addosso
l'ho toccato io a sé bene e lo riposo
sul tavolo perché fa abbastanza vomitare
grazie grazie della lezione di anatomia
comunque fa questo è il coltello lo
prendo per non so per autodifesa ma solo
sapere che è stato scortato quell'affare
mi fa schifo
c'è un proiettore funziona
c funziona che bello ci vediamo bel film
ok ragazzi film non so cosa si vede
molto male non sembrano ripresa da
vicino di una specie di anelli the non
ho idea di che cosa sia ma noi
proseguiamo non ok non c'è niente va
bene andiamo avanti e chiuso dall altra
parte ma credo che la chiave sia ancora
nella toppa di dentro allora usiamo il
cacciavite scassi niamo spingere la
chiave non serve a nulla devo riuscire a
recuperarla da sotto la porta dopo
averla spinta fuori
mettiamo il vecchio giornale mamma mia
che genio che genio motivo
mamma mia che genio non so come come mi
è venuto in mente ma ci sono riuscito
andiamo chiudo la porta perché non si sa
mai
poi magari c'è qualcuno qui dentro cos'è
sto schifo così tanta morte malattia
quaggiù suppongo che la roma che fossero
i nemico e una lumaca ma che schifo
oddio
vabbè io non faccio domande e andiamo
avanti questo c'è qui dentro
niente perfetto mi facessero cos'è sta
roba verde sangue verde grande
abbastanza da perdere così tanto e qui
intorno non vedo molte salamandre
giganti
ok quindi sto per incontrare una
salamandra gigante
no perché non ci tengo professore diario
bio medico del dottor petris la perché
questa roba
se qualcuno di voi così fa solo a
leggerlo stop il viso perché come al
solito non lo leggo che sesto schifo
oh mio dio un alieno sottovuoto che
bello era un aliena sottovuoto
[Musica]